but by the way now it's right to move c7
okay yeah so
oh yeah
yeah triangulated with this king nepo
just shook his head that he thought it's
a repetition of moves i think
wow i mean it's the clock right
less than 20 seconds now for nepo it
must be panicked in seconds
it's just been a nice
nicely played queen ending from karjakin
and king b6
i think b6 should be the move now no so
the queen's on d5 so definitely don't
take that a4 pawn because queen c6 check
but
king a5
okay
even king b4 maybe or king b4 queen c6
doesn't really matter the thing is he
has to go to ca king takes on a4 and
then karjakin will win this game
yeah
wow and we're possibly 40 so there's a
one-second increment three seconds on
the one for napo still playing can't
believe that he made this mistake
yeah wise king just comes against sergey
he's not going to be saving this game
simple plan of king b6 of course you
don't resign because
you try until the very last
queen endings yeah maybe some miraculous
perpetual checkered repetitions well he
had to resign yeah queen b7 coming next
and a new queen
impressive by carriackin
that end game
crazy middle game though that's uh yeah
tactical flurries exactly but